dernière en date 12000 euros pour cet
habitant de vélizy-villacoublay pris en
flagrant délit de dépôts sauvages le
maire n'en n'est pas à son coup d'essai
depuis 2010 est pascal thévenot a pris
la décision de faire payer les
contrevenants se la faire de tous et on
est tous victimes de dépôts sauvages et
notamment en 2017 il y avait le quartier
louvois où on était en train de
s'éteindre au chantier on supprime une
dalle de vingt mille mètres carrés dont
il y avait des camions c'était facile de
venir déposer des gravats parmi les
camions du chantier est donc là on en a
eu assez c'est là qu'on avait mis on
avait déclaré en préfecture une caméra
de surveillance et si j'avais dit que le
premier qu'on attrape je lui ramène et
ça a pas raté il y en a un qui a balancé
attaqué par l'administré puis blanchi
par la justice le maire a choisi de
continuer la lutte contre les dépôts
sauvages et les incivilités j'ai fait
passer un
délibération au conseil municipal qui
pour des frais de nettoyage donc ce
n'est pas une n'est pas une amende c'est
des frais nettoyage forfaitaire de 150
euros + 150 euros par kilo dire que de
temps en temps on fait des opérations
coup de poing grâce à la
vidéosurveillance le but faire prendre
conscience aux administrés de l'impact
des dépôts sauvages une initiative
plutôt bien accueilli moi je pense qu'il
a bien raison quand je pense qu'il faut
pas mettre ses déchetteries un apport
nous en même temps il ya ce qu'il faut
pour les mettre ailleurs que sur le
trottoir
donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
attaque venant du maire à un moment
donné les trotteurs sont pour tout le
monde tout dépôt sauvage doit être puni
voilà et on n'a pas le droit de salir la
nature comme ça depuis 2010 est la
mairie n'est quasiment plus victimes
deux dépôts sauvages même en forêt